I'm gonna not peace be with you
welcome to another episode of the D show
my next guest from a tender young age of
seven years old all the way until he was
about sixteen seventeen years old he was
a company his mother at many of the
different evangelical conventions
conferences the likes of Benny Hinn TD
Brooks and some of the world famous
preachers that are out there and then he
woke up he realized hold on what's going
on all the scandal that's involved with
all of these preachers out there all the
corruption and then he just left
religion altogether got involved in a
nightclub scene and the club scene the
party scene but he's here on the Dean
show today to tell us his story we want
to know where he's at today that's the
important thing not yesterday but today
where is he yet you're gonna hear his
story here in the detail we'll be right
back
this is the how's it going
we introduced you as the evangelical
Christian kid who was out there at all
the different evangelical conventions
conferences right yeah yeah I was going
at at a young age I was going right away
when'd you start it was it right seven
years old I mean as long as I can
remember five six years old I remember
waking up in the morning my mom you know
doing the Bible studies and so on and so
forth but when I got to like seven or
eight that's when I can't remember
actually going to different conferences
and starting to see all these things
firsthand like all the different
preachers and pastors and such now your
mother she's deeply involved of many of
these were conventions yes right do they
have like you know a certain
organization that sends out blast emails
to say okay this person is in town Joel
Olsteen or TD I mean I said his name was
as TD what's TD jakes TD jakes he's like
a big-time and he's one of the top ones
actually he's he's huge in the southern
part of the United States she vote
involved in a network now she gets all
of the information and then she would
just grab you by her arm and say let's
go yeah when she first started out one
of the one of the big ones that she used
to follow was this one past name or
Cirillo and once he started going in
then she started seeing the emails and
phone calls and different things like
that and when she started to get these
notices of going over them and she would
take me with and we'd be there and it's
it's pretty much too like a same thing
is like a church service but it's like
an extra step further you know okay that
age you're really not I mean at 7 years
old you just follow along with your mom
but at what age did you did you start to
see like hold on these people are like
down in front of me speaking in tongues
yeah I can't even understand yeah you
know a lot of this weird stuff going on
and then you were just like driven away
from religion all together because it is
that what age was that what happened
tell us talk to us man I mean right in
the beginning when I wanted when I was
starting like when I was young under 10
years old I was going into the what they
call like the the children area of the
convention where they would put you with
like an assistant pastor I guess you
could say and they're just doing like
different songs and different things
like that and kind of doing the same
type of thing you do at a service with
your teaching you different things about
the Bible but as I got to be like 10 or
11 I remember telling my mom I don't
want to I don't want to be in that area
I want to go up where you are at you
know and I would start to see you know
everything you know people like falling
down in the spirit and people talking in
tongues and you know people just kind of
starting crying out of nowhere you know
and I guess these are people just like
getting in in the into the the moment
you know but I always wondered like and
at that point I was like am i doing
something wrong because I'm not feeling
anything I just kind of like I saw it as
like this is just interesting that
everyone else is doing this but I'm not
doing any of that you know you mentioned
once that you saw a lot of people just
falling yeah then you felt like hold on
I supposed to fall cuz yeah and I just
you know blend in kind you kind of just
go it's a domino effect yeah they were
basically there was a couple times where
basically they would they would line you
up and he would start carrying around
what they called anointing oil and it's
something where I don't know the
specifics of about it basically it was
like he would put his hands on you he
would have the oil and then once he put
the hand on the person they start
speaking in this tongues and then they
would fall back and it was almost like
to say in layman's terms like a conveyor
belt he was going down the line and each
person's going down one by one and I was
at the point where my mom saying next me
everyone goes down and they get to me
and I'm thinking like okay I got to feel
some something's gonna come up some
gonna happen and then he put his hand
and I'm like okay I'm just gonna cuz I
didn't I didn't there's nothing I just
went back to just to follow the crowd
you know you don't want to be the odd
one out yeah I don't mean because if I
stand there I'm thinking like I'm doing
something wrong you know I'm not suppose
we doing this you know so so let's for
many people that don't know what this is
speaking in tongues in they're gonna
hear right now
go I think in one of those videos that
was TD was a TD jakes
TD jakes and speaking something mhm and
that's something it sounds like
gibberish I mean it's it's it doesn't
fit in any language bracket and you can
kind of make things up jiggy jiggy jaw
jaw whatever it's just a gibberish yeah
I mean did you did I go through your
mind when you're listening to this yeah
I mean there was each person that you
would hear doing it doesn't in a
different way you know it's not like
there's there's one universal tongues
that everyone speaks it's uh you know my
mom would do it and other people would
do it and uh and it's just that their
way I guess of being like filled in with
the Holy Spirit you know this is just
like getting caught in the moment I
guess uh-huh
so okay now you're going through all
this and at what point did you realize
hold on this stuff did it make sense I
mean I would there were moments of
course I was young I was listening here
and there and some things I would listen
to stories that they were talking about
but that aspect of it I never
experienced it myself I never like I
never fell back I never spoke in tongues
I never I never did these things so I
never kind of like bought into that
aspect of it but the religious part of I
think from my opinion I think I was too
young tongue and grasp all the different
concepts of one God and you know what
Jesus son where does he fit into the
equation and this time I never really
asked those questions when at that age
you know yeah now you got Benny Hinn you
also attended some of his commands once
twice many times many times and he's
like one of the biggest yeah he's uh he
actually sells out stadiums like you go
to sit like these big like football
stadiums and basketball arenas and
they're stacked with thousands of
thousand eight line Nightline some of
these major news stations they've done
some some background checks on him and
looked into you know his extravagant
spending and right you know people who
are inside of his institution how do
they pick the ones they want to go
onstage at that point they have staff
members that go through and give them a
quick quick interview and they'll ask
them can you you know what's wrong with
you oh I've had rheumatoid arthritis of
my left shoulder
I can't lift it all of a sudden can you
lift your shoulder because we can't lift
your shoulder you can what spirit
according to Andrew the screening system
has one purpose to keep the truly sick
or disabled away from banning him you
were close with him and many of them
have come out and exposed him for being
somebody who's you know basically just
ripping the people off it's a big big
business yeah and you know in this this
market I mean looking back now as I do
my research now just to kind of like see
where where all this stuff was and what
I was actually into that's more or less
what I always find you know like even if
you just take a random name and you go
to Google or you go to Wikipedia you
want to watch some of these websites and
and it's it doesn't lie like that's what
usually goes on the top of the list of
some sort of scandals something was
there there was actually a really
well-known singer back in the day he was
like one of the biggest among the kids
name was Carmen and it was always said
like oh no he's single he's done
celibacy towards God like he doesn't
want to you know get a wife or anything
like that and then I read up recently
that he based got a scandal where he was
had an affair with someone else's
pastor's wife or something like that I'm
not exactly sure on the specifics but
you find most of these things going on
with mostly these guys there's some sort
of scandal behind there's some kind of
scan something yeah and most of these
met these guys were either good sales
men good hustlers guys who are out there
knowing looking at a way to to cheat
people and I mean this is a real good
business to be in yeah because Jesus is
a product and they're selling that
product that's what they call him a
product yeah and they're selling them
and and and people are just many are
just blindly following yeah you you
snapped out of it I mean you weren't
really hypnotized by it but when we got
to a certain age but you you mentioned
something that you just wanted to
believe in one god yeah I got to the
point where I started looking at all
this stuff and I started because my dad
on the other hand he was Muslim and he
was telling me things about Islam as
well but then I um I go back to my mom
now she was telling me certain things
and I was kind of conflicting so I got
to the point where I was like I don't
even think I want to believe in any of
this other you know Jesus Muhammad this
this this I just want to believe in got
it I believe that exist but just that
one annex I don't
have to worry about any of the other
specifics you know mm-hmm we're going to
take a break comment and we got back
with more of your story Hamid story here
on the Deen show it's a simple to
understand Islam means submission look
at the word submission not to yourself
not to your desires not to anyone or
anything because at the end of the day
you get something you always want more
you get some weed you want more you get
some drugs you want harder drugs you get
a girl you want a nicer girl you get a
car you want a nicer car you get a spawn
a nicer house we've got so many precious
by enslaving yourself worshiping God
loving God with submission to the one
who created you and by what you've been
going and seeking his pleasure you get
pleased and enter back here on the Deen
show with a very interesting story Hamid
we're at a young age seven years old
you're accompanying your mother yeah who
was attending dozens I mean dozens of
dozens of these evangelical conventions
and really whenever we do a show you
know we try to make sure that you know
we're not trying to disparage on anybody
or hurt anybody's feelings but sometimes
you know in delivering the truth you
know when you love somebody so much and
someone else is telling you that this
person is cheating on you this person is
no good for you and they even bring you
the pictures and they bring you the
proof you know those things hurt but
you're doing it out of the love so it's
not hard to find if you want to to know
that many of these people who aren't I
mean most of they're shysters
Benny Hinn that's the world's greatest
scammer they're just really out there
taking advantage now of people so
clarify as well like the people that I
had met along the way
like all these people that I used to
hang out with and go to dinners with and
being in that area these were great
people I used to like I met people from
all walks of life people from other
countries and they were just always
great people you know nothing ever
against that it's just now when you go
into the realm of what they're actually
learning yeah it's different so I mean
that you met a lot of interesting people
a lot of good people you know who really
are maybe that's that's their journey
they might have to go through that but
if you do the one thing you call upon
your creator your maker alone he'll
guide you he'll facilitate a way so I
mean it's interesting you know you can
hear right now and then one of the the
some of these tactics and tricks like
Benny Hinn you can hear him right now he
says look into my eye I'm not a liar if
these eyes I have never lied to you
never
I never will when somebody you could
just anybody who's just using not led by
emotion you could just hear what he just
said call the people up and said I'm not
no liar you know and and definitely
someone like this is is someone who's
who needs to be exposed and people need
to be aware of now let's keep going
along you you you left this at what
point where did you just tell your
mother I'm not going to any more of
these conventions how did that work out
from there I mean they were basically be
times where I got to the point where my
mom would ask me like y'all you know
it's coming up again in Dallas or it's
coming up again in in Orlando and such
and they said like you know where to go
and Mike you know what I don't think I'm
gonna go this time I would say like
schoolwork or something I just didn't
feel like I was going you know and then
it was started get to the point where
you know she would stop asking me and
she kind of knew that I wasn't you know
into it as much anymore you know but
then from that point on like I started
kind of doing things where it wasn't the
best and I started hanging out with a
couple of people I didn't get anything
anything bad stuff I still hold on to my
parents you know where they were they
really grounded me strong and ever had a
sip of alcohol never smoked a cigarette
any drug in my life and I you know I I'm
proud of you know I'm probably cuz they
taught me that but I started doing
things that were definitely you know
just kind of taking me towards the wrong
path hanging with the wrong people a
little bit you know you kind of get it
went into the party scene now a little
bit yeah you went into that you went
that route yeah okay so how long did
that last
I mean that was like maybe four or five
years something like that and it was I
was just kind of like going to school
going to work and then doing that on the
weekends and everything and it's uh I
kind of left got in the backseat a
little bit you know so what made you
realize that look there's got to be did
you ever think about there's got to be
more to life than just partying there's
got to be more to life than just follow
my desires okay you grew up you know
being exposed to something that I mean
you you know the basic belief is that
God sent his son to die for the sins of
the world that he was one with the
father son Holy Ghost three gods but one
Trinity and the suicide of God that did
this this I mean besides the shysters
and the you know all the hocus-pocus
stuff that you know we've seen the
belief did that make sense I mean when I
started actually
researching into Islam I started trying
to compare the two I tried I tried to
one thing that I do in my life in
general is that when I when I tried to
go for something with I purchase
something I go for something I try to
discount it I tried to kind of like find
the wrong in it because then it makes it
wrong you know what doesn't make sense
you know so I like for example Islam
that's what I tried to do where I tried
to like basically see what was wrong
with this I would see like okay Muhammad
what was the validity of what he's
saying I tried to look at you know how
does how do Muslims believe in Jesus I
said how do they believe in other
stories in the Bible what do they think
you know I just started comparing the
two and finding all different things and
the more and more I learned I just
started seeing that you know Islam was
making a lot more sense a lot of a lot
of more common sense a lot of the stuff
in an Christian era was more faith you
know just kind of like you know just
believed you know like this is something
where you just have to keep doing what
you're doing follow this path and just
believe you know it's kind of like just
trust me yeah but if you're gonna put
your life savings into a house or a car
and someone's just like hey I want a
full inspection but I said no no no just
trust me yeah we would dentist you know
the huge investment I don't know huge
investment but this is our this is our
here after after here so this is very
important I mean you did the smart you
did a smart thing you just want you took
a scientific analytical approach and the
more you did that you know you came at
it like a skeptic and what things just
made sense
yeah I mean to be honest what started
the whole thing was I just I started
really looking at like what happens like
you said one that when life does end I
mean like my mom is not gonna be here
forever my dad is not gonna be a forever
family friends is not gonna I'm not
gonna be forever you know so what does
really happen and people say some things
but something that has to like click
something has to make sense you know and
the more and more I started searching
into Islam and learning about how kind
of like that way of life went and
everything it's there was not one thing
that I found with this within Islam that
maybe think it wasn't wasn't right every
every every single time I learned
something new it's kind of like I was
going up a ladder and just kept going I
felt like I kept going in the right
direction you know but someone just
watched some some anti-islamic film and
he says man maybe we gotta send us a
guy's CD he hasn't you know seeing all
these supposed you know terrorist attack
that Muslims are blamed for we know it's
I was going to do with that or Islam
oppressing women Islam being backwards
did you get exposed to these
misconceptions every every single thing
and as I was researching into Islam
I started getting you know different
things from from different friends
Christian friends as well you know
exposing the different things you know
man these guys are terrorists and
the women they're oppressed you look at
them date they have to you know wear
this thing you know and I think it falls
into the category of apologist it's a
strong word but it's ignorance you know
I mean once you start learning about
something the more your research into
something the more you understand
something and if you don't put any
effort into researching it then you're
you're just left with with a blank
thought of something you don't really
know about it you know in the nightclub
scene the party scene mm-hmm the just do
as you want atmosphere hanging around
with guys many playing PlayStation
smoking weed just wasting their time was
their fulfillment not saying you were
doing that but I'm sure you've seen that
and many of you for doing that those
people that you know to this day who are
still involved in bad things did you
have any fulfillment doing any of these
things and the people that you know that
you look back now are they happy I mean
to be honest when I first started going
into it it was there was a sense of fun
you know something new something
exciting it was like everything was new
to me but then as I went down the line I
started realizing in my head like man
this is this is the same thing every
week every single Friday every Saturday
this is it's the same music it's the
same people it's the same kind of like
watching a rerun of the same TV show you
know and it's there's no other episodes
coming on it's the same thing you know
so I started thinking like I think this
is getting played out I don't think this
is you know what what people do the rest
our life you know on this type of
atmosphere and the people that do do it
still it's I think they're still they
feel a sense of emptiness something is
still kind of missing there so they try
to fill it with this tons of music and
tons of friendships and and then
unfortunately get the alcohol in the
system and now it takes you away you
know mm-hmm so what made you finally
decide that I don't want to live that
life you know and it brought you to
where you are today as a Muslim you
finally accepted Islam is that right
yeah I did humble I mean it's for me
like I said I just I just kept finding
things that made complete sense I find I
found things that that didn't you know
kind of hurt they put things in it in a
wrong perspective you know everything
that I found it just it made complete
sense to me you know so as I started
practicing you know the prayer and you
know doing all the fasting and what's
funny is I actually was fasting before I
even became Muslim you know and I
believed in these certain things none of
the health benefits but also like just
the belief of it you know I got it for
my dad and now that I become Muslim it
just I think is just a little bit easier
I feel like I when I need help I kind of
go to him and then you know everything
kind of makes it makes its own path you
know give us an example of something
because many people are here you say it
makes sense it makes sense give us one
of those things one of the main things
that now you can share with the people
about Islam that just makes sense the
one thing for me before I became Muslim
I had no sense of a prayer I really had
no sense of I mean I remember my mother
always saying makes you pray make sure
you do this ask God for forgiveness do
this but I had no discipline to it so
one thing now when I go with it when I
when I started going with Islam is the
five daily prayers and the obligatory
prayers and going to gym on Fridays I
felt like I thought it was a discipline
that it gives me so I'm it made sense
like it just it's a system that there
works you know and then when you when
you need the help that you that you have
to get and when you want to make this
connection with God that's something
we're just giving faith that you
actually can go in and and it's
something that's tangible you know
something you're actually getting in you
know it's it's it's you know it works it
works we're gonna take a break and we'll
come back with more of hamish story here
on the Deen show why do you choose to
copy someone else's style and swag just
to be unoriginal impersonators well you
could be something different something
unique and not follow these unguided
manipulators they say imitation is the
highest form of flattery but it's a
slippery slope and it's easy to fall
into a false sense of what is really
reality there are billions of people in
this world are all completely special in
our own special way but then we start to
listen to the same music watch the same
movies and start doing the same things
day after day
after they you can start to be stuck in
a rut and you don't even know it you're
not happy in this life and the actions
begin to slowly show it you're always
looking for the new hot fad to follow
but in reality of life is meaningless
and it only gets more hollow all of
these temporary pleasures never leave
the true happiness you find yourself
saying and doing things and wondering
how'd I get into this mess mistakes and
regrets are so easy to create but that
doesn't mean what you did in your past
has to seal your fate what if life
wasn't meant to be so difficult and
crazy where every second and every
minute of the day just feels like mental
slavery where every problem that comes
into your life the solution to your
problem doesn't have to seem so hazy in
fact if you get on the right path and
get be crystal clear because down this
path there is no doubt no confusion no
contradiction and nobody telling you to
just have faith and hey somehow it'll
all work out at the end of the day this
existence we all live in did not just
make itself something divine and
all-knowing brought you into this world
with a clean bill of health the animals
the trees the seven seas the air you
breathe all live in complete coexistence
and in perfect harmony back here on the
Dean show with Hamid and next phase of
life you go through the partying French
for partying following desires reserved
empty is a void there yes it's so empty
feeling yeah you got it gets played out
quick yeah now did you always have this
firm belief that there is a maker of
mankind that there is a designer for
this whole universe and everything in it
100% I mean too many things that you see
just in your daily life it's like you
have to if you don't question I think
your perspective is wrong I think if you
can't look at the trees and look at this
just different stuff that's going on the
animals I mean just a sense of being
able to like just breathing you know
it's it's it's a miracle and every every
step that you take you know so it has to
be a crater that has to be something
that made all this you know now there
was the the one of the main differences
there's a lot of similarities because
the message comes from the one from the
source the creator of mankind so he sent
messengers and they all came with the
same message where should the crater not
his creation and they came with
evidences and proofs and then when
people started to talk to you as we
talked before about the concept of the
pure monotheism in Islam that you only
worship the Creator you don't go through
Jesus Muhammad or anybody you just
worship God just the maker of mankind
that how did that resonate with what's
inside of you it's I go back to again
made sense you know it's I think
anything in life that you look at if
it's if it's simple the simpler things
in life are always the best you know I
have other people in my family who are
or actually the of the Catholic faith
and there's a lot of complexities in
that you know with the rosaries and
going to confession and kind of like
giving your sins to it like somebody
behind a door you know and it's it's
there's a lot of like questions that
kind of if something you do starts at
like questioning more with four or five
more questions then I think it kind of
gets too complex and I think this is
just simple you follow God Muhammad
peace be upon him was the final
Messenger of God and the message is
before that peace be upon all them were
bringing the same message that's simple
to understand very simple worship the
Creator not his creation that made sense
and what was the final thing did you
procrastinate a little bit cuz a lot of
people when they look into Islam when
they're brave enough to step forward
because there's a lot of vilification
going against people are been lining
Islam there's a smokescreen and people
are trying to you know there's a lot of
deception but when you finally looked
into yourself you said it made sense
right but now did you procrastinate in
the beginning to finally accepting Islam
I think for me procrastination was my
hardest hurdle you know my mind my worst
hurdle to go through I mean I was I was
fasting during the month of Ramadan I
will go to Juma with family I would sit
in the back just to kind of see what was
going on this before I you know I
accepted Islam and I and I I just kept
on saying like now I'm gonna go a little
mime search a little more just to make
sure I want to you know but then I
started to think like man I could end up
being 56 years old or I mean it might
not go till tomorrow you never know what
happens and now it's I procrastinated
too much you know so I just said I I
believe in everything that everything
that's inside this book I believe in
everything that the Prophet Muhammad
peace be upon him brought in a message
inand I think that I just had to take
the leap of faith it's almost a little
bit of faith that goes into it you know
but I think rastenn a she could be like
a big killer if you kind of let it let
Shaitaan get near too much you know why
is it so important and you actually do
some spoken words in poetry yeah and
people can see we're gonna show a little
clip of yours so go and stand for days
like sheep in the line
for those new Jordan's the Xbox of the
new iPhone 5 there's always gonna be a
new one for you to go out buy something
a little bit different each time for you
to throw the old one to the side but I
repeat what I said to you earlier than
what you're doing is not the path to
happiness I mean think about it what if
the one who created you and gave you
life be the one to give you eternal
bliss if you're starting to wonder why
this life is feeling like a test that's
because it is and guess what there's a
book that gives you all the answers to
this life's quiz it's name is the
glorious Quran sent by the laws immerse
you to the final Prophet Muhammad peace
be upon him which decides you can find
absolutely no wrong that what motivated
you to do this the spoken word it kind
of goes back to like when I was younger
I was really big into music I was really
huge into the hip-hop into the you know
just like the the lyricist of it you
know like all the Rhymes and rhythms and
everything and I guess they kind of
stayed with me as I as I went in and
accepted Islam and certain things would
kind of come up in the bike back in the
day I would have certain freestyle to
kind of go on the back of my head I said
little things that kind of going in when
I'm doing my daily things you know but
now when I get into it I other things
started going into it I started like
putting music to the side I don't listen
to it anymore and now I kind of had
different things that came into my head
and I started wanted to like just help
spread it to other people who are maybe
interested in knowing so I decided to
make like a YouTube channel and kind of
got you know an idea from you with with
the Deen show and I decided to put
something out there you know first step
just but it's don't procrastinate just
puts him out there you know so I wrote
some things down and made the video and
insha'Allah somebody you know saw it and
help someone else out you know was
looking looking for the truth you know a
few more questions we're almost out of
time why why is it so important to
really reflect about the purpose of life
what is the purpose of life why is that
so important you think because if you
don't it can it can just pass by okay
you're just kind of like on cruise
control you know you have to reflection
is a very huge thing because if if you
don't look back and and see what you've
been doing and what possibly have could
come up and what happens I mean this
body that we're given this life that
we're living right now this ups up until
God willing we get to a 90 or 100 or
something we might not make it to that
point you know so we have to reflect and
see what is the true purpose why are we
here why is it that you know this earth
is the small little speck compared to
the rest of the universe what
makes what we have to do why do we hit
what are we supposed to do while we're
here and once you start like just
contemplating these thoughts then you
got to start researching just take the
next logical step and start researching
if you find anything at all that goes
against common sense anything that all
that just it says you know what I think
that's the hogwash is horrible then let
it go but if it does make sense if so if
starts to becomes to be clear then it's
it you got to be able to kind of take
that leap of faith and don't
procrastinate you know don't
procrastinate then for your your mother
who's out yeah probably watching this
yeah probably you love your mother
in Islam I mean do you feel you even
respect her more because Islam is
telling us doesn't matter if she she's
Muslim not Muslim you have to respect
your mother you have 200 pursuit to your
parents you know because you know by
being obedient good you know a righteous
child you know serving her obviously if
she told you to do something bad it's
against God use you kindly tell me I
can't do that but what what what would
you like to share with your mother she's
watching right now I mean just just kind
of you know kind of let like some of the
defenses that you would kind of normally
get and kind of put it to the side and
the media and all these things that they
put out there about Islam in general
just kind of like put that to the side
for a minute and really research the the
true origin I mean you know pick up a
book Quran you know and this book isn't
it's not it's not kudi existent it's not
gonna give you something I mean if
anything it's gonna open up eyes a
little bit you know and I think if even
if like I said same similar other thing
if something doesn't make sense if
something is is against what your and
your nature believes then you know put
it down but if it's done if it does
start to make sense than the you know
and that if people can dig because as
soon as you open the verbatim word of
God the Quran all over it's telling you
to worship the maker of mankind the
creator of mankind and doesn't have any
kid anything in there that goes against
humanity as a whole it's calling you to
everything good everything organic we
call it everything that would just bring
peace and prosperity and human beings
life thank you very very very much for
being able to have a show and another
person's story how they came to this
beautiful way of life Islam Islam simply
means submission to the will of the
Creator the one who made
you made this universe and everything in
it Jesus pray to the crater the Lord's
Prayer Oh Father who art in heaven
hallowed be thy name thy kingdom come
thy will be done
that's islam submission to the will of
god not submission to the will of jesus
or anything in creation and if you can
understand that and this is something
that resonates with with what's within
your very nature the worship of the one
creator that's it that's what Islam is
all about and doing good deeds preparing
for the Day of Judgment paradise at the
end or the Hellfire and if you really
have a sincere want for this then do the
very basic thing ask the crater alone
there's a lot of confusion out there
right and who's the the the leader of
confusion the the enemy to mankind if
you believe in a creator than you
believe that there is a a Satan a devil
who's trying to deceive mankind so ask
the creator for help and when you follow
many of these Benny Hinn's and all of
these other people who are out there you
know exploiting people you see I mean it
doesn't take too much to see the
corruption that they're involved in
exploiting the people and the false
message that they're sending so stop
take a look
analyze put your emotions to the side
and ask the Creator alone very simple
homework I'm giving you to do ask the
Creator alone to guide you that's it
we're not asking for your money we're
not gonna send you a nice but special
genie in a bottle
just ask the Creator alone to guide you
and don't forget as we cut out we
started a hashtag on Twitter
priceless blessings of the Creator get
with that on Twitter follow us on
Twitter like us on Facebook and share
this message of peace with the world
peace acquired by submission to the will
of your maker the maker of mankind the
one creator we'll see you next time
God willing until then peace be with you